In light of all that's
happening right now,
it is important to feel
prepared and feel safe.
Luckily, our newest
sponsor has you covered.
These are the end times,
and you wanna be prepared.
But every time you reach
for a survival tool,
it turns out to be one
of your many sex toys.
Sex toy, sex toy.
This isn't a boot, it's a sex toy.
But what is the opposite of that?
Introducing the Tactical Shlong Omni-Tool
from SurvivoTech.
The Tactical Shlong is the
only multipurpose survival tool
specifically designed to look
like a freshly-used sex toy.
(intense music)
Use the Tactical Shlong as a flashlight,
to break glass,
(glass shatters)
to put out a fire, to
start a fire, chop wood,
and thanks to SurvivoTech's patented
Always Glistening technology,
the Tactical Shlong looks
like a freshly-used sex toy,
so no one will try to steal it.
Get out of here, burglar.
Use the Tactical Shlong Omni-Tool for
nunchuks, to land a plane,
fetch, pretend penis,
unicorn, walrus,
that workout thing, drug dancing,
hit a garbage can.
And on behalf of everyone at SurvivoTech,
I just wanna say that
we're with you, America.
We believe in you, and we'll
get through this together.
The great failure of society is upon us.
Be prepared with the Tactical Shlong.
(dog pants)
Good boy.